yo the thing that you uh you just
mentioned in
i think it was a no jumper but you
talked about how soldier boy was locked
up
there
yeah he was in pc for people who don't
know that's protective custody
absolutely
usually pc is child molesters
yep uh like sex offenders sex offenders
child molesters green lighters people
don't want it
right yeah et cetera
who wants to be out with them right
that's what's confusing to me right
because
you if you're in that position you
almost have to ask for that or fight for
that
or do you think that the jail realized
no we got to put him over here because
he sold your boy i don't do that chris
brown wasn't in pc
so why was he in pc
like chris brown wasn't in pc no
hey chris brown the real one low key
yeah that's what i'm saying
like and he's like like a rnv pop dude
so how
if he didn't go to pc what is his excuse
if he's big draco
gangsta rapper whatever then he's
supposed to be killing a [ __ ] before
like bro
[ __ ] crazy it's funny because you were
in jail during his whole entire
like 60 day yeah i was there
his career got revamped for about two
months yeah and then like you said it
was just a meme thing yeah it was really
just a meme moment
and then the meme was over and you know
that's how it is man
you know i didn't realize it's like that
with this rapture like
people do anything to get attention it's
like they just do like
i didn't think it really was like that
until i started seeing like
damn like people really just start beeps
because they like about to put out a mix
table or album or something like bruh
it's not that serious if you pop me you
pop in like
whatever take some time taika came back
hey if tiger came back i tell this man
you're just one hit away
because people counted that man out
that's what i'm saying and i heard
six seven seven one radio when you went
to jail it was over for tiger yeah
i was i heard is it what was that that
tastes like
oh yeah this okay i like this uh then i
started hearing back to back stuff like
wow
that guy he's been having a run
yeah he's been having a run for sure
yeah uh shout out to tyga